Speaker 1: A major night of news involving the alleged
sale of presidential pardons, sexual harassment,
anti-Semitic remarks, all sorts of allegations
against Rudy Giuliani. Donald Trump is implicated
in these allegations, and we'll get to that sort
of subsequently. But let's start with where this
all began, which is a lawsuit. The lawsuit has
been filed by Noelle Dunphy. We are naming her,
despite her status as the alleged victim, because
she has gone public. This is not a situation
where there is a Jane Doe who's looking to remain
anonymous, at least publicly. Daily Beast article
explains harassment suit against Rudy Giuliani
full of graphic allegations. A New York woman says
the ex-mayor sexually harassed her while she was
working for him, claims that he previously denied.
When you look at the article, you learn about the
70 page complaint filed in New York Supreme Court.
This goes back to January where Noel Dunphy filed
a summons, says she was hired by Rudy in 2019 for
so-called business development work, that he
did not pay her as promised and subsequently
fired her in 2021. The summons also alleges that
Rudy Giuliani made anti-Semitic and racist remarks
during, quote, confused and hostile alcohol laced
tirades and demanded sexual favors. The lawsuit
was filed Monday. Remember, the first step was
the summons in January. We now have a lawsuit.
The lawsuit includes extraordinary detail, much
of it probably inappropriate for this show.
It includes allegations of forced oral sex and
intercourse, details of Rudy's sexual preferences,
which is gag worthy. The revelation that Dunphy
recorded some of the interactions. There are
tapes. Lordy, there are tapes. And the lawsuit
seeks $10 million in damages. A statement was
put out by Rudy. It says Giuliani vigilantly
and completely denies the allegations. He plans
to thoroughly defend himself, that it
is harassment and attempted extortion.
I don't know that we need to go through all
of these elements, but they relate to demands
from Rudy that Dunphy work naked or an American
flag laden short shorts that he purchased for
her. These are like hyper specific allegations. I
mentioned the forced oral sex Rudy talking about
fantasies related to the television show Billions
that Rudy was constantly taking Viagra and would
sometimes, dear God, point his erect penis and say
work couldn't be done until that was dealt with.
Video conferences would include requests
or demands for disrobing. There were text
messages where these are included. I mean,
this you know, it's much tougher when there
are recordings and text messages to write this
all off as made up requests to shower together.
Um, it's all it's all outrageous. And then
one of the big elements of this, which we're
going to discuss on its own because it is so
outrageous. Dunfee This is now from the article
Dunphy claims Giuliani told her he was able to,
quote, break the law. Because he has, quote,
immunity. And asked if she knew anyone who needs a
pardon because he was selling them for $2 million.
He told Ms.. Dunphy that he or she could refer
individuals seeking pardons to him so long as
they did not go through the normal channels of
the office of the Pardon Attorney, because then
they'd be subject to disclosure. And this goes
on and on and on. 2020 Plan In February 2019,
the complaint notes, Giuliani told Dunphy about
Trump's plan if he were to lose. Specifically,
Giuliani said to Dunphy, Trump would claim
there was voter fraud and say he won. This
was discussed at several meetings with Giuliani
and Lev Parnas. This is absolutely stunning stuff.
Absolutely stunning stuff. There's another
article which we won't go through and details
from Business Insider. Rudy hit with bombshell
rape lawsuit. Ex staffer says he demanded oral sex
while he took calls from Donald Trump. Has America
ever been more wrong about someone than about Rudy
Giuliani after 911? I mean, that's one question
that certainly comes up. Bill Cosby, I guess
maybe. And so much of the last five years now has
to be sort of revisited or reinterpreted through
the lens of this lawsuit, if you believe it to
be credible. And I have no reason at this point
to to doubt it. There are audio recordings, there
are text messages. There is this is genuinely a
bombshell when we think back to that Borat scene,
Sacha Baron Cohen, where Rudy Giuliani after the
fact said, oh, I was just tucking in my shirt.
It certainly seems less harmless in the wake
of these new allegations. Dunfee has receipts,
20,000 emails, text messages and recordings. And
let's not ignore this is a lawsuit is a civil
proceeding. Let's not ignore the potential for
some of those documents and records to become
relevant in potential criminal investigations
against Rudy Giuliani. So that's the lawsuit.
Let's now focus in on the pardon aspect of this